hi guys welcome back to yang speaks this
is zach grauman
one of the co-hosts of this podcast with
andrew look we recorded this episode
um right after the georgia election and
we were elated we're really happy and
you'll hear from andrew myself and
and jermaine johnson who's a south
carolina state representative
who we love and we're super excited um
but in between right as we're about to
press uh
send if you will and put this up for air
um
our capital um was being stormed by
um some really violent violent
protesters and
um insurgents is another word for it um
and we just wanted to say
um to us it's disturbing
and we want everybody to stay safe so if
you're in dc or anywhere please stay
safe
and we hope that our message at yang
speaks
very much is for the unity of our
country
over any political party we're all
humans and in america in this country
we're all we all are american
um so stay safe we love you guys this is
a very happy podcast
we didn't want it to be tone deaf so we
are aware of that and we'll be making
more comments as the day's
um days continue thank you all love you
guys
all right welcome back to yank speaks
this is zach roman one of the co-hosts
of this podcast with andrew we
are in a very very happy mood for the
future
of the country because the georgia
runoff
for senate happened last night and the
democrats won not one
but both seats and we're fired up
and look i don't care every democrat
republican both purdue and kelly lefler
the two republicans that lost
are two individuals that when the covid
pandemic hit
went to their stock portfolio and sold
their stocks before
telling anyone else that's the type of
scumbags they are and we've kept them
out of congress we being
the democrat party or just americans or
particularly georgians
so i'm proud of you georgia andrew and i
are fired up
i've got so here's we got today andrew's
on the road but he recorded a love note
to you
um and everybody and kind of his
thoughts so we're gonna we're gonna hear
from andrew quickly and then we've got
my one of my favorite humans on the
planet uh south carolina recently
elected
south carolina state rep jermaine
johnson
and he was our former south carolina
campaign chair down in the state when we
were running for president
you want to hear from him because he's
been on the ground both in georgia and
south carolina mobilizing voters and
mobilizing the
black community on this race in a lot of
key issues so
it's a fascinating perspective it's a
fun episode
we're rejoicing today tune in
yank speaks
[Music]
oh my gosh georgia we did it
you did it this is incredible tens of
millions of americans hundreds of
millions of americans can look forward
to our government actually being able to
rise to this challenge
and do some work on our behalf because
jon ossoff reverend warnock are on their
way to the us senate
mitch mcconnell's getting demoted and
you helped
make this possible thank you
particularly to all of the folks
who knocked on doors phone banked text
banked
donated did the work trying to give us
this chance
to flip the senate to make georgia blue
but also
to give our entire country a functional
government
i am so happy i am so grateful this
should be something that we celebrate
in like an incredible way because
i can't even remember a victory this
important since uh trump lost
joe i know it's funny that seems like a
little while ago even though he hasn't
been inaugurated
um but so grateful to everyone who put
in the work that
it was tremendous spending time with the
people
of georgia and this victory is for all
of us
uh thank you thank you thank you let's
go let's go
georgia it's a new day in america 2021
let's do some work and yang yang those
of you who supported our efforts in
georgia
those of you who even came
uh you know the math mansion humanity
forward georgia
though you're already there obviously
you live there
but everyone who did this i hope you
embrace this feeling and reflect on what
this means
we can be the difference makers
in our nation's shared destiny
it's awesome i'm so proud of us i'm
proud of you
i'm so grateful uh let's take advantage
of this time
and now let's put the pressure on
joe biden and his newly democratic
senate to try and get two thousand
dollars cash relief
out and that's just the start we helped
make it happen
i am so freaking proud of us and let's
go
2021 georgia this is the best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time for everyone's favorite ad
hellotushy
new rear new you baby in 2021
don't just make a commitment to wash
your hands every time you go to the
bathroom
go the extra mile and use a bidet
which is pretty cool and wash your
underside so the future of toileting has
arrived guys i love
this thing um this sounds weird but
bidets are
way better than uh
frankly the traditional toilet paper
that we've all been using um
so i've been thrilled with uh using
hello tushy
and the new brand new
hello tushi 3.0 bidet attachment
is fantastic and you save money on
toilet paper it is more
environmentally friendly it is cleaner
um i freaking love this thing
um so there's no need to wipe
you just use it wash off and go and
every bidet attachment
has a 60-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty so you can try it
risk-free which is pretty awesome
because i know people are very sensitive
about how they use the bathroom what
they do in there
this if you try it and you love it you
have a brand new routine if you don't
like it no worries so
here's the deal if you go to
hellotushy.com yang you'll get 10
off plus free shipping so you could try
out the bidet
and get 10 off and get free shipping
it's a special offer for our yang speaks
listeners go to hellotushy
t-u-s-h-y dot com
slash yang for 10 off that's
[Music]
hellotushy.com
what a night what a night
this is exciting stuff and to discuss it
you can hear the hearty laugh
he's my favorite laugh there's like one
person
you can hear it it's beautiful there's
very few people that have such a hearty
laugh
and give better bear hugs than the one
and only jermaine johnson
but i want to make sure i introduce him
right because this man is officially
a south carolina representative right
now
and who's elected just sworn in what
jermaine a couple weeks ago december 1st
man december december 1st
so about a month ago um and he was um
our south carolina campaign chair and
wanted to make sure jermaine was on here
to kind of talk about the significance
of
uh the election last night in georgia
where recording this this just happened
um and you're listening to this about
about a day and a half since
um the news came out but the democrats
have won both seats in georgia
and it feels pretty good so jermaine how
are you feeling man
tell me your network the communities are
the political world you're operating in
what are you sensing bud
oh my god man well first of all thanks
for having me on here man uh you know
it's always a great
a great time to spend with my buddy zach
man and looking at that beautiful hair
he's got
you know it's not falling out yet only a
little
not yet but i mean what what's going on
man is i mean just the magnitude of what
we have witnessed down there in georgia
uh with this historic win you know
reverend warnock is going to be the
first
african-american to hold this seat you
know and i i hold that true to my own
heart
because i am the first african-american
to hold my seat
and only was the second democrat ever
elected to my seat i mean
so you know with individuals making
history river will not make a history i
remember
when i was with the campaign with you
all and we were down in georgia we met
reverend warnock down there
and i mean just just the history behind
this what we have done
in georgia to have not one but two
two democrats coming out of georgia
going up there to help us out with the
senate i mean it is just
it is it is you know it's something that
we did not ever found could be possible
uh but we're sitting here and we're
standing on the shoulders of giants like
congressman john lewis uh god rest and
soul and now we are going right to the
future and i'm just excited man
i always try to think about what the
average person is looking at this right
where it's like the average american
like looking at what just happened
georgia and
for i think the average person like man
george has been a reds that's like a
southern state that's like a red
like that as it gets forever you know um
and here we are where
it was a toss-up on the election
election night
right like it was super close they had
to go to a runoff and
historically in runoffs in georgia but
also elsewhere around the country
democrats don't do very well we don't
usually turn out as well
um it's not our forte and so not only
did we perform well in both the
presidential and this runoff
um we won like democrats literally won
so in your opinion like what what's
changed down in these community from
from the people you're talking to
like what what is driving that
um is it the black community is it some
of the work stacey abrams doing i know
there's like
i mean the aapi turnout's higher in
georgia like thoughts on on what you
think you've
what's happening yeah well it's it's a
complete conjunction of everything you
just stated there right
because you know we have people like
stacey abrams who is tired of uh voter
disenfranchisement
uh for the people down there in georgia
so she got out there instead of you know
fading into the background like a lot of
these uh candidates do after they've
lost the race
you know she jumped out that the
forefront said all right well you know
whatever happened to me
won't happen to anybody else you know
and she got out there and she really you
know took this whole election by the
bull horns
and drove it home i mean she was vocal
she's been in the community she's been
doing the work
you know she's been organizing and
strategizing and has and
this is paid off you know so what we're
seeing is that people are just tired of
things you know even some of the
republicans are tired of what they saw
they you know they believe in democracy
they believe in you know uh
what we're seeing in terms of the the
fair the fairness of our elections and
you know we have a president right now
who's up there who's who's talking trash
about
you know how these elections are being
conducted and
you know with a state like georgia where
it's ruby red like it's been
imported to have a present that's
talking bad about his own part his own
people
you know people are just tired of it man
the child they want stability back in
the white house they wanted civility in
the senate they want stability in the
house
and they all came out you know we even
saw that a
large percentage of people went out and
just voted for war not because they were
like listen we're just trying to get
this thing done
and the only way you can explain that is
either the people came in and voted war
not
himself or they did one hockey purdue
like they're tired of it so these people
are split
on what they're trying to do but they're
tired of the mess they're tired of the
immaturity
the time of the the baseless lies
you know the things that are just coming
out of washington right now they want
something different
they want the future to be here and
we're embracing the future so you know
the people that i'm talking to
in south carolina they're even saying
we're even more energized here in south
carolina now
you know it's like man we can do that
because we saw what happened with jamie
harrison and lindsey graham
and we're like man this mess you know we
can do exactly what georgia did so i
i imagine that south carolina is headed
in the same direction that georgia is
because we
see it is possible and now we have a
renewed faith in this entire process
yep and i think so for context everybody
um lindsey graham um and jamie harrison
ran
senate race that just happened in
november this year
jamie had a ton of momentum the election
looked close and it wasn't close
and the takeaway is is likely
the inability to vote there's a lot of
people that say they like them when they
answer polls they do but they don't vote
and stacey abrams like for
agree with her disagree with her
wherever you land what she did
after losing her governor's race she's
like i would have won if people were
able to vote and so she went out there
and did the freaking work and look they
registered
i think it was 93 95 percent of eligible
voters
in the state and like past real laws
like if you get a new driver's license
in the state of georgia they say do you
want to register to vote or you
automatically register to vote it is
there's a bunch of things she did that
we should do around the country
right and regardless how you see this
democracy has to reflect its people and
when it doesn't bad things happen you
know um
yeah yeah absolutely i mean and it just
uh you know we have black voters matter
with natasha brown
i mean we've got all these individuals
who've been out there doing the work man
um a good buddy of mine with amplify
action
uh brandon upton i mean we have people
that
and it's not even just uh it's not even
just the people of georgia like the
people of georgia came out and they
showed up and they voted
but people from all across the country
came out to
to support and and came to georgia but
also instead of going down there a lot
of people did phone banking
a lot of people sent you know financial
contributions i mean it was like all
hands on
deck uh for this for these two races
here man and it definitely paid off
and it was just so great to have stacy
abrams that uh you know at the helm of
it all
you know directing traffic making sure
things were getting done the way it was
man i mean it's just an exciting time
[Music]
all right guys we have a new sponsor and
i wanted to tell you about it because
it's
pretty cool if you're tired of using
some of these big name
household products that you don't really
know where they came from do you know if
they're good for the environment you
know
if they're good they're treating their
workers right you honestly don't and so
i want to talk to you about
something called public goods which is
essentially a one-stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price so everything
from lily coffee to
the shampoo to toothpaste to pet food
it's your new everything store but it's
thoughtfully designed for the conscious
consumer
i've tried a couple things they have a
surface cleaner that i think is pretty
great comes in a cool spray bottle
i have tried their olive oil recently
that i love
i'm not the best cook but i have been
doing a little bit and they've sent me
some cool stuff
uh and their toothpaste actually pretty
awesome i've just replaced my crest
nonsense that i've just been grabbing
at you know the pharmacy when i go
um but they have literally it's it's
everything so that the box that i've
i have of public goods um
goods um has been ranging from like food
to pet food to
uh cleaning materials rather than buying
from a bunch of single product brands
public goods member can buy all their
premium essentials
in one place in a beautiful website
beautiful aesthetic they look cool they
are good
um they're ethically sourced and they um
they obsessively develop this stuff uh
to be free of things that are unhealthy
or harmful additives that are still
common on drug and grocery store shelves
um and very very committed to making
their products healthy and safe for
humans which is why we love them because
there's this commitment to
frankly humanity we've talked to public
goods and we've now just worked out as a
new sponsor here an exclusive deal just
for yank speaks podcasts listeners so we
receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase that's 15
off your first order no minimum purchase
so they're so confident that you'll love
their products and come back again and
again they're just going to give you 15
bucks
spend on your first purchase pretty cool
so go to publicgoods.com
yang and use that or just use the code
yang at checkout
y-n-g so it's p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com forward slash yang to receive 15
bucks 15 off your first order check out
public goods guys it's pretty freaking
cool
[Music]
yank speaks is brought to you by helix
sleep guys i'm moving
into a new apartment in new york city
very very exciting
uh it's gonna be a little home office
situation
very very coveted friendly i'm pumped
and i had to
get rid of my old mattress because uh
i've outgrown it it's been a while so
i've gotten
a new mattress from helix sleep and it
comes in this beautiful box extremely
comfortable
designed for me i got to get all new
sheets on it and stuff too getting your
match is awesome and helix sleep is
one of your best options out there so
basically how it works in typical yank
speaks fashion helix sleep does some
data gathering before you get your
mattress you take this quiz
it's like two minutes not even really
two minutes a few it's like you know
let's call it 90
seconds um and it matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the right
mattress for you so if it's soft or firm
or you like the side you're a side
sleeper or a back sleeper
so when you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you get the mattress
it shows up at your doorstep
you can add on sheets and pillows or
whatever else you need for your bed
and it comes right to your door within
10 business days pretty cool they've
been awarded number one best overall
mattress pick in 2020 by gq
and wired magazine which is pretty cool
so these people i want to be the guy
that gets to vet
out mattresses you just sleep on them a
bunch of times but anyway i vetted out
this one and it's freaking great so here
you go
go to helixsleep.com yang take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress they'll give
you the best sleep
of your life and i mean that because
i've had some of the best sleep of my
life in this new mattress that i'm
moving in my new apartment with so right
now helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners that's helix
sleep.com
yang it's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com get
up to 200 bucks
off your order and two free pillows
check it out
this is cool and uh it's amazing and
look the you know is the fate of the
the world at least for the next two
years um and now that the democrats
we basically have a 50 50 split in the
senate um with kamala harris
as a tiebreaker um i think look it's not
filibuster proof so for those of you
you know if you're listening this you
don't like the the left or you don't
like the far left i think you're still
gonna have like a moderate um
like moderate government um which is a
general win um
for you know like the like the whole
country i think if we're finding some
sort of compromise but the other piece
is that we have so many big problems
jermaine there's so many big things that
we need a government that's not gummed
up by mitch mcconnell and it won't be
as much anymore you know what we need to
look at now is the fact that uh
we can actually start to prioritize the
things that need to get done
you know um and i'm excited about it i'm
excited about that opportunity
uh because what we have now is we can
actually get our strategies in place
which is
you know the the number one thing on top
of the ticket needs to be getting this
coronavirus thing you know
uh under control but in conjunction with
uh
getting people some of this cash relief
you know if we could do both of those
things man i mean it you know the
americans
could turn around hey man so that's my
that's my good question for you
i think it's like the numbers are not
out yet but we have the presidential
numbers and
they're going to be relatively similar i
think it's
very very fair to say that the biden
administration
owes the black community a large favor
um
yeah uh you know it says its
yeah and you can that stems back from
south carolina where joe was
um he did okay in nevada i believe and
then
had an epic comeback in um south
carolina you could go down the cities
you know where uh i'll never forget
where
um there was a black community leader in
detroit when um
when he won michigan and he said we used
to pick cat
we used to pick cotton now we pick
presidents it was like it was like such
a it was an awesome moment
and uh he was pretty badass like i said
that and
uh but the media was like what so what
like but i think it is important to
understand this like
because obviously not not all black
people are the same and like this
that's a tough that's a that's a tough
um
burden if you will or um for the buy
administration so in your opinion
um and the opinion of those around you
if you can and you're maybe your
constituents and in your community
what when you say that by administration
owes the black me a favor what is what
does that mean what what should that
look like what should be on their agenda
for for this community
well the first thing that definitely
needs to come back to the forefront it's
got to be the conversation around
reparations
you know and talking about what does
reparations look like uh you know this
has been a hot topic for
you know a number of years about you
know this conversation of what
reparations is and how it would work and
all that he has got to mention that he
has to
you know he's got to talk about that and
see what it can be what could be done
um he's got to uh lean on on our leaders
such as jim clyburn
and talk to congressman clyburn about
you know uh
what can we do with with the plan that
congressman clobber had talked about you
know helping individuals in the
struggling communities
um he's he's got to talk about those
different things that really uh
affect us not just the typical
conversation of of criminal
you know criminal reform and that type
of stuff uh he's not talking about other
things because like you said not all
black people are the same we don't all
think alike
you know there's there's sometimes in
these different communities there's a
a disconnection between rich black and
poor black you know so we've got to
figure out how to bridge that gap and be
able to meet
everybody's needs and i think a
conversation around reparations would be
a great starting point
to see what that looks like and how that
can really affect everybody in the black
community
what that would do for all black people
and all black americans erica mccloud on
our team says his twos like look every
time you're talking about black people
if you're talking about
criminal justice reform you're doing
everybody's disservice um
it's important but it's not it's not the
end-all be-all and uh to me
what i love talking with andrew when you
talk about this is like it's the economy
stupid like starting with
like resources in people's hands and
yeah opportunity
um which they sound like catch-all
phrases but the ability to move up in
societies
is key to democracy it's key for a
thriving economy and
particularly in coronavirus right now
right if these communities
particularly communities of color are
getting hit the hardest
um oh we're getting decimated man that
has to be front center you know
he has to you know uh this community's
uh
all down here where where you know these
little small towns are just
completely destroyed uh you know
most of it started because of natural
disasters and things like that with the
lack of resource that this
music getting but then you have on top
of that you put the pandemic in place
and then you know these these uh
businesses are going out of business
they don't have anybody to spend money
there
you know so i mean we're completely just
being being destroyed down here
um so something has got to give you know
some some cash release something has got
to come to these people
so they can you know make it through
this pandemic and
you know not only come back but come
back stronger if they don't get
something done
if they don't start solving the problems
you're talking about like where do you
think
your communities or communities in
georgia where we're talking about now
where do you think they start going to
is it is it violence and unrest
is it becoming republican is it uh
um a new political party like what where
does people hit their threshold and what
does that look like when they're at wits
end in your opinion
i believe this is the end-all be-all
right here
yeah i believe this is what we've been
waiting for for you know
some a long time you know having you
know the senate having the house having
the presidency
we've been waiting for this you know we
fought for this and if they do not hold
up there in the bargain
this will be the end of the base of the
democratic party you know the
individuals will be
headed to either on their own party or
they will be headed to the republican
party
or and it would be a little bit of civil
unrest you know it's going to be all of
that
because we fought for this to happen and
it's like
fighting for uh an individual who's not
gonna fight for you
so you know we're gonna make sure that
we're gonna hold this person accountable
we're gonna hold this administration
accountable
if they don't do it they will be voted
out they will also be one-term president
uh they will be one-term individuals and
we will move forward
uh with coming up with new strategies
and new plans to move us forward
because if if this party uh having all
this power at this point
does not do what they said they will do
for us we'll go elsewhere
and i promise you that you know i will
be a part of that group
that leads my community somewhere else
because i'm going to make sure that we
are getting what's deserved and what we
are
what we have earned and properly it's
country of a party people have a party
um yes i agree with you man
i um i guess i think the takeaway is
this man
like right now
we can honestly say here you go joe
like here you go like yeah
but you got the ball you got the pitch
you're on the mountain be the man for
the moment man
be the man for the moment like the like
ignore
we are divided we are pissed off we are
angry
we've put in a lot of blood sweat and
tears to get to where we are joe you've
got
majority in the house in the senate we
need a vision
we need big ideas and we need execution
and we need them fast
um yeah so that look i hope he is the
man for the moment
um frankly he has to be um to your point
or it's not gonna end well um but
look man jermaine like that said i'm a
big believer in celebrating wins
um and tonight or last night and this
weekend
the georgia runoff was a big win um both
of the democrats but i also believe for
the country i do think it's
generally good that we can have a fun
potentially functioning potentially
functioning government
over the next years that's where next
two years
anyway jermaine um love you brother
thank you for being on here
um this is jermaine's now a recurring
yes on yang speaks and is not going
knowing any going anywhere so um i
appreciate you
you hopping on in like a uh a
celebratory episode
here yeah so stay in touch and stay
awesome right brother
absolutely man appreciate you having me
on here brother yes sir
thank you guys have a great rest your
day hope you celebrate this one
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you